well and uh now some important breaking
news related to kovid senior government
sources have told sky news that the
prime minister is minded to move to plan
b as early as this week in the face of
the micron variant
and that mr johnson is worried that if
he doesn't make the move now
he'll regret it in a month's time
well with me is our deputy political
editor sam coat sam let's talk about
that news first of all
what does moving to plan b mean
well there are two key components of
plan b one is to encourage people to go
back to working from home
and the other which also looks like it
could be introduced is a form of vaccine
passports in other words having to prove
that you've had uh two jabs in order to
enter bigger venues indoors and and
outdoors and this all flows from a
cabinet discussion yesterday where chris
whitty appeared chief medical officer
was clearly very worried about
making clear to cabinet ministers he was
very worried about what
he was seeing in the data
and there was a discussion with figures
like michael gove
the leveling up secretary suggesting
that government needed to do something
government needed to be seen to be doing
something uh that's of course taking
place before uh the events later in the
day unfolded uh vis-a-vis the party with
the rule-breaking notion and we're told
the prime minister told that he would
regret it if he didn't move now
in a month's time that's because
latest information on the rate of spread
of the micron variant is pretty alarming
that's right the transmission
of the omicron variant of coronavirus
does seem to uh be higher than uh
previous variants of coronavirus that
means it can spread through the
community quite quickly now ministers
scientists are hoping that the wall of
vaccine protection that's been built up
over the last few months particularly
with the booster will mean that when
people get coronavirus if they get this
variant it's not particularly serious
but there are maybe in the region of
five million people unvaccinated 89
percent of people have had uh uh the
first jab which means 11 that haven't
that's still potentially quite a lot of
people completely unprotected and
therefore if it passes quickly through
the community quite a lot of people
ending up in hospital that's what
ministers seek to
want to seek to head off protecting the
nhs is always the first political
priority and that's why boris johnson is
potentially moving this week it was only
friday that senior government figures
were saying it'll be a couple of weeks
maybe the 18th before any decisions were
made it looks as if the scientists are
now saying we can't wait that long of
course all of that is going to affect
this christmas and may divert attention
from
what appears to be now a pretty serious
crisis of credibility for the government
over this
so-called party last christmas i think
whatever the government announced in
terms of working from home measures
vaccine passports it doesn't allow them
to escape the political heat that
has been generated overnight with the uh
that footage that you saw a few minutes
ago
of government aids downing street aides
laughing about an apparent party that
took place last year now what do we
understand that happened on december the
18th inside downing street last year
well we understand that there were maybe
three dozen aides from different bits of
downing street gathering together at an
event some of whom had a planned event
it appears yes it appears that some
people came in from home especially for
this event so it wasn't just people
having drinks at the end of the day it
was something a bit more than that there
were party games
and the like now for the last seven days
ever since the daily mirror broke this
story downing street have said no rules
have been broken and then on some
occasions they've said no party
was held uh you can have an argument
about what the definition of a party is
but at the bot the bottom line is people
watch that footage of downing street
aides joking about an event that they
seem to know would be against those tier
three rules that were introduced just
two days before uh in london and you get
the very strong impression that there
was an event that they know uh shouldn't
have taken place now the response from
conservative mps is furious listen to
tracy crouch she's the chatham uh mp i'm
not even going to begin to justify or
defend the party in downing street we
all deserve a fulsome explanation and
apology and swiftly take anne-marie
morris
it's not on at the very least they
should admit their blatant error and
apologize for breaking the rules they
imposed on society talking to cabinet
ministers there is concern about this
suggesting that suggestions that heads
should roll the heads of whoever was
pushing boris johnson
to essentially uh endorse a strategy
that didn't involve coming clean over
what happened just every year again as
far as the prime minister himself is
concerned we have heard some calls from
some opposition of him to resign
but we know dewey a he wasn't at the
party and b he may not have known it
took place
uh ian blackford the snp leader in
westminster last night called for boris
johnson for uh to resign that's the
first time he's actually uh done that uh
boris johnson we believe was not at this
event largely civil servants some uh
political advisors we think were there
uh too but the one fact that cabinet
ministers have repeatedly felt confident
enough uh to say uh on the airwaves and
downing street have said behind the
scenes was that the prime minister uh uh
wasn't there although of course danny
street denied that there was any kind of
rule-breaking event uh at all
interesting listening to liz trust a few
moments ago she was completely
sort of um unwilling to uh say that she
believed the downing street account she
always just said well somebody in
downing street says it isn't true you'll
just have to listen to them that's what
cabinet ministers do when they're not
quite sure who to believe can't have
pleased her very much that there she was
giving her first foreign policy speech
at britain's foreign policy
think tank first question from a senior
foreign policy diplomatic journalist
about this
it's never uh
pleasant when a cabinet minister gets
diverted from their agenda because of a
scandal particularly in number 10 you
have to tread carefully but at the same
time liz trust is one of the more
combative
ministers and she's one of those people
who might line up to replace boris
johnson should he
one day step down so who knows maybe she
relishes every moment in the limelight